Giang Truy sửa thảo để xóc giảm lệ phía trúc bà được với một số tại sản của công dân số,
của thế nhảm đất nhận chuyển nhợ khi đăng ký quên xả hiếu, quên xử dụng được giảm
mười phần chăm mức thú lệ phía trúc bà. Bởi ô tô chưởng rồi từ chính trốn trở xuống,
chương hợp nộ phía trúc bà lần thứ 2, rồi đi, mức lệ phía trúc bà được lệ xóc giảm
ngã mười phần chăm. Lối phê mua tô nộ phía trúc bà lần thứ 2, rồi đi,
rồi đi, mức lần cơ sở cả thời điểm kê khải lệ phía trúc bà.
Để được hưởng ở đây, công dân phại xử dụng tại khoảng định zanh địa từng mức độ 2,
khải và nộ phía trúc bà thời hưởng dẫn của công cộ sản hệ. Lống thời đất ứng các
nhiều kẹn về tích hợp thông tin trên giúp V&EID, vướng nhà đất các thông tin tần được tích hợp
gồm mả sấu thời cả nhân thông tin về quyền xử dụng đất, quyền xử hữu tại sản của
bên chuyển nhọc và nâm loại thông tin giấy tờ cơ bà khai quy định.
Lối với autos em này các thông tin cần được thích hợp gồm mắt sổ thui cải nhấn.
Thông tin đang tìa xe, phọc, quyền sở hiểu tại sản của bên chuyển nhợ, và năm nay thông tin sẽ tờ thật quy định.
Hoài lệ phía trước bà bộ tại chính nề sốt viện nhiều khoảng phía.
Lệ phía khác cho công dân số màu gồm phía khai thác, sự dụng thông tin trong cơ sở rữ liệu hột định.
Lệ phía đang kỳ thường chú, đang kỳ tạm chú, ra hạn tạm chú và cách hộ.
Công dân số cũng được nền sốt miễn lệ phía cấp đổi, cấp lại thể cắn cước và phía cùng cấp thông tin li lịch từ pháp.
Chong lý vực rao thông đường bộ, dưu thào để sất miễn lệ phía cấp bằng chứng chi được hạt động trên các loại phương viện rao thông đường bộ.
Nội với chường hợp đổi, cấp lại sẽ có ra hảo của tế.
Một số chường hợp cấp đổi, cấp chuyện nhất đang chỉ xe tạm thời và biển sổ xe tạm thời, cũng được nền sốt miễn lệ phía.